[Music]
the Met Gala is one of fashion's biggest
nights and one of the Internet's
favorite source for memes here's a look
back at nine of the most outrageous
looks in Met Gala history there were the
hippy vibes mary-kate and Ashley Olsen
served us in 2013 and Solange's
out-of-this-world ensemble in 2015
curious how the singer sat down and her
Giles Deacon creation us - but it's not
a met gala without Beyonce queen be
stunned at the 2015 soiree in this
dazzling Siobhan she that left very
little to the imagination the jewels the
high pony
we gave us modern day I Dream of Jeannie
and who can forget Kim Kardashian's own
Givenchy moment in 2013 the floral print
had many asking who wore it best
Kim or mrs. Doubtfire but it was Kanye's
contact moment that caught our eye at
last year's madness ex machina themed
bash 2016 also marked Gigi Hadid
and Zayn Malik's red carpet debut as a
couple the former One Direction singer
seriously rocked this robotic arm head
pieces aren't anything new at the Met
Gala
but the Louis Vuitton on Madonna's
blonde locks was a head scratcher the
Met theme in 2013 was Punk and no one
pulled it off better than Miley Cyrus in
Marc Jacobs I feel like Marc really kind
of got it just perfect and as soon as I
saw it I didn't really feel like it
needed anything he really knows what
song Rockwoods but perhaps one of the
most memorable looks of the Met Gala
belongs to Rihanna RiRi shut the carpet
down on account of the epic train on her
yellow goop a cake
the Chinese Couture was so massive it
required handlers and immediately
inspired fans online my favorite meme
stuffed-crust Rihanna what has been your
favorite look of Matt galas past
tweet me at D direct oh and I'll retweet
your pics
[Music]